In a hundred years?
Two hundred years?
And these are three really profound changes
that are not, like, future stuff.
This is stuff we take for granted today.
So this lifecode stuff turns out to be a superpower.
It turns out to be this incredibly powerful way of changing viruses,
of changing plants, of changing animals,
perhaps even of evolving ourselves.
It's something that Steve Gullans and I have been thinking about for a while.
Let's have some risks.
Like every powerful technology, like electricity, like an automobile,
like computers, this stuff potentially can be misused.
And that scares a lot of people.
And as you apply these technologies,
you can even turn human beings into chimeras.
Remember the Greek myth where you mix animals?
Well, some of these treatments
actually end up changing your blood type.
Or they'll put male cells in a female body or vice versa,
which sounds absolutely horrible
until you realize, the reason you're doing that
is you're substituting bone marrow during cancer treatments.
So by taking somebody else's bone marrow,
you may be changing some fundamental aspects of yourself,
but you're also saving your life.
And as you're thinking about this stuff,
here's something that happened 20 years ago.
This is Emma Ott.
She's a recent college admittee.
She's studying accounting.
She played two varsity sports. She graduated as a valedictorian.
And that's not particularly extraordinary,
except that she's the first human being born to three parents.
Why?
Because she had a deadly mitochondrial disease
that she might have inherited.
So when you swap out a third person's DNA
and you put it in there,
you save the lives of people.
But you also are doing germline engineering,
which means her kids, if she has kids, will be saved
and won't go through this.
And [their] kids will be saved,
and their grandchildren will be saved,
and this passes on.
That makes people nervous.
So 20 years ago, the various authorities said,
why don't we study this for a while?
There are risks to doing stuff, and there are risks to not doing stuff,
because there were a couple dozen people saved by this technology,
and then we've been thinking about it for the next 20 years.
So as we think about it,
as we take the time to say, "Hey, maybe we should have longer studies,
maybe we should do this, maybe we should do that,"
there are consequences to acting, and there are consequences to not acting.
Like curing deadly diseases --
which, by the way, is completely unnatural.
It is normal and natural for humans to be felled
by massive epidemics of polio, of smallpox, of tuberculosis.
When we put vaccines into people, we are putting unnatural things
into their body
because we think the benefit outweighs the risk.
Because we've built unnatural plants, unnatural animals,
we can feed about seven billion people.
We can do things like create new life-forms.
And as you create new life-forms, again, that sounds terribly scary
and terribly bothersome,
until you realize that those life-forms live on your dining room table.
Those flowers you've got on your dining room table --
there's not a lot that's natural about them,
because people have been breeding the flowers to make this color,
to be this size, to last for a week.
You don't usually give your loved one wildflowers
because they don't last a whole lot of time.
What all this does
is it flips Darwin completely on his head.
See, for four billion years,
what lived and died on this planet depended on two principles:
on natural selection and random mutation.
And so what lived and died, what was structured,
has now been flipped on its head.
And what we've done
is created this completely parallel evolutionary system
where we are practicing unnatural selection and non-random mutation.
So let me explain these things.
This is natural selection.
This is unnatural selection.
(Laughter)
So what happens with this stuff is,
we started breeding wolves thousands of years ago
in central Asia to turn them into dogs.
And then we started turning them into big dogs
and into little dogs.
But if you take one of the chihuahuas
you see in the Hermès bags on Fifth Avenue
and you let it loose on the African plain,
you can watch natural selection happen.
(Laughter)
Few things on Earth are less natural than a cornfield.
You will never, under any scenario, walk through a virgin forest
and see the same plant growing in orderly rows
at the same time,
nothing else living there.
When you do a cornfield,
you're selecting what lives and what dies.
And you're doing that through unnatural selection.
It's the same with a wheat field, it's the same with a rice field.
It's the same with a city, it's the same with a suburb.
In fact, half the surface of Earth
has been unnaturally engineered
so that what lives and what dies there is what we want,
which is the reason why you don't have grizzly bears
walking through downtown Manhattan.
How about this random mutation stuff?
Well, this is random mutation.
This is Antonio Alfonseca.
He's otherwise known as the Octopus, his nickname.
He was the Relief Pitcher of the Year in 2000.
And he had a random mutation that gave him six fingers
on each hand,
which turns out to be really useful if you're a pitcher.
(Laughter)
How about non-random mutation?
A non-random mutation is beer.
It's wine. It's yogurt.
How many times have you walked through the forest
and found all-natural cheese?
Or all-natural yogurt?
So we've been engineering this stuff.
Now, the interesting thing is,
we get to know the stuff better.
We found one of the single most powerful gene-editing instruments,
CRISPR, inside yogurt.
And as we start engineering cells,
we're producing eight out of the top 10 pharmaceutical products,
including the stuff that you use to treat arthritis,
which is the number one best-selling drug, Humira.
So this lifecode stuff.
It really is a superpower.
It really is a way of programming stuff,
and there's nothing that's going to change us
more than this lifecode.
So as you're thinking of lifecode,
let's think of five principles
as to how we start guiding,
and I'd love you to give me more.
So, principle number one:
we have to take responsibility for this stuff.
The reason we have to take responsibility
is because we're in charge.
These aren't random mutations.
This is what we are doing, what we are choosing.
It's not, "Stuff happened."
It didn't happen at random.
It didn't come down by a verdict of somebody else.
We engineer this stuff,
and it's the Pottery Barn rule: you break it, you own it.
Principle number two:
we have to recognize and celebrate diversity in this stuff.
There have been at least 33 versions of hominids
that have walked around this Earth.
Most all of them went extinct except us.
But the normal and natural state of this Earth
is we have various versions of humans walking around at the same time,
which is why most of us have some Neanderthal in us.
Some of us have some Denisova in us.
And some in Washington have a lot more of it.
(Laughter)
Principle number three:
we have to respect other people's choices.
Some people will choose to never alter.
Some people will choose to alter all.
Some people will choose to alter plants but not animals.
Some people will choose to alter themselves.
Some people will choose to evolve themselves.
Diversity is not a bad thing,
because even though we think of humans as very diverse,
we came so close to extinction
that all of us descend from a single African mother
and the consequence of that
is there's more genetic diversity in 55 African chimpanzees
than there are in seven billion humans.
Principle number four:
we should take about a quarter of the Earth
and only let Darwin run the show there.
It doesn't have to be contiguous,
doesn't have to all be tied together.
It should be part in the oceans, part on land.
But we should not run every evolutionary decision on this planet.
We want to have our evolutionary system running.
We want to have Darwin's evolutionary system running.
And it's just really important to have these two things running in parallel
and not overwhelm evolution.
(Applause)
Last thing I'll say.
This is the single most exciting adventure human beings have been on.
This is the single greatest superpower humans have ever had.
It would be a crime for you not to participate in this stuff
because you're scared of it,
because you're hiding from it.
You can participate in the ethics. You can participate in the politics.
You can participate in the business.
You can participate in just thinking about where medicine is going,
where industry is going,
where we're going to take the world.
It would be a crime for all of us
not to be aware when somebody shows up at a swimming pool
and says one word, just one word,
if you don't listen if that word is "lifecode."
Thank you very much.
(Applause)